[Music]
and wrong guy News Sunday submitted by
eye holes a man is freed after 17 years
in prison when his doppelganger is found
[Music]
the wrong guy in prison the whole time
just cuz he looks exactly like him well
you can't blame dude I'm so lucky I
would like every Asian guy out there Oh
God it's perfect yeah this story's crazy
so Richard Jones spent 17 years in
prison for China he didn't commit
early black I don't know their ethnicity
because I know like a long time ago a
lot of black people were incarcerated
accidentally or purposefully yeah I
suggested I thought gout sucks ask off
17 years of your life Konica so back in
1999 there was this card with the actual
Ricky so that they call em Ricky and so
that's the similarities is that they
have similar names so Ricky the actual
do that committed the crime he was in
this car with some other dude they were
all on drugs they got in the car
together they drove off to a Walmart at
that Walmart they sent they came across
the victim this woman who was trying to
answer her car and Ricky he ends up like
wrestling with her to grab her purse he
ends up getting away with her with her
person her cell phone and in that whole
scuffle she ended up having a small
injury like some scrapes underneath and
so that's when the victim was shown if
she went to police and then the victim
looked through over 200 mug shots and
she could she didn't get a clear look at
at the perp and so by the time that she
was looking through all these suspects
she was telling the police like you know
what I didn't get a good look at this
through like I really can't tell you for
sure like who it is oh it seems like the
police are just like so eager to just
like let's close this case it's just
fine to me she was like oh no yeah so
she was like I really don't know and the
guys in that car so what happened was a
back at Walmart there was a security
guard that was able to chase that that
cart and was able to get a license plate
number from that car so they were able
to attract
the two other dudes that were in that
cart but apparently these guys I don't
it seemed kind of foggy there because
they said that baby they couldn't really
tell who he was either like from his
phase like from the mug shot which is
where mm thinking like wrenching guys
friends or something like hundred guys
even end up in the same car I don't know
what happened there
but though all these witnesses and to
create or to like everyone didn't get a
good look at Ricky's face the actual
perp so that's when the victim says you
know what like I can't tell you for sure
but out of all these mug shots that you
guys are giving me which look like this
I'm going to make my decision purely
based on the skin tone and so that's
when she ended up picking him out the
lightest one the lightest one because
that's what she remembered was that he
was light skinned and so he ended up
going to prison he kept saying like it's
not me I'm innocent like I love you in
there I [ __ ] go to jail for that he
is from Kansas City Missouri
right Richard Jones the innocent dude
the other guy named Ricky Amos
he's from Kansas City Kansas and that's
where the crime was committed and so um
I actually don't even know how they
didn't believe him could even had an
alibi with family like I haven't even
been like across the state line like how
could this be me it's not me so [ __ ]
frustrating yeah and it talks to because
when he got arrested he had he had a
baby girl it was only a couple months
old so her entire life for 17 years she
never got to know her dad ever he also
had another daughter Brom not sure who
he was at that time so she missed out on
his kids lives and so finally after all
these years it was about 15 years I he
had or even in prison he's just like
from then like I'm innocent like you've
been fighting in court this whole time
they don't believe them because they
don't have any other evidence other than
the witness testimony that's the only
thing a witness testimony was even
saying I don't know exactly god damn it
why the [ __ ] did she decide to go I
don't really know but
just send this one to jail I just don't
know why she gladly kept pressuring in
Basel cost up her sugar they should be
in jail
yeah [ __ ] up so then Richard he found
out if there was a lot of inmates saying
like man you look just like this guy
named Ricky like at this other prison
and so after finding that out that's
when he contacted his attorney and he
also contacted attorneys at the Midwest
Innocence Project and the project for
innocence at the University of Kansas
law school well he's smart I woulda just
gave up and start complaining for 17
years straight I would have trying to
escape every single day if I can yeah my
man I don't belong here yeah and so he
ended up contacting these people and
they were able to track down Ricky
Emo's and they pulls up his mugshot he
was like right next to him oh my oh was
he in that one this is the innocent
Richard this is the guilty Ricky holy
[ __ ] Wow
that's cool that even [ __ ] insane
they decided to look the same for 17
years pretty useless is it both trends
bro it's good to the same even if I got
robbed and I saw him like face to face
and I got a clear view I'd probably
still pick the wrong guy just because
you just follow how close they are
how can you tell them apart in a scuffle
do you know yeah I'm doing the same
white t-shirt and everything Richard
said that when he finally saw the
comparison of their much loss he stopped
being angry because for the last 15
years like I see what you guys like I
read uh yeah I got you 17 years look at
my job ed he was just so angry didn't
know what was happening to him but now
he has answered you like okay I get it
because he's like you know being in it
you can clearly see the differences you
clean us but then he was like if I
remove myself in that and I see it from
you know the outsider's perspective I
can't tell the difference also another
state / - oh it's the same city that
shares the border Kansas City it shares
a border the city is
in the middle and then one side is
Kansas and the other side is Missouri
all is it all so Kansas City Kansas and
Kansas City Missouri it's a nine minute
drive this great open money we're not
sure if he's going to be suing but I
wonder how the girl feels like oh yeah
there's this video that it was like one
of those silhouette kind of videos we
can't be your face but she's just like I
did know she's just she feels really bad
it was just like oh my god like they
probably hated him too
why do you look the same yeah she's just
saying like 17 years like how can you
repair this man like she lost all that
chunk of his life and all that time with
his family so sad are they gonna put
those cops in jail probably not how they
look too similar
they even got hooked up with the same
outfit white t-shirt and cornrows and
they're even close to 6 feet tall so
goatee this yeah the entire facial hair
they weigh about they both weigh about
200 pounds go to the same barber he's
going to same barber the lockers are
right next to each other at 24 hour
fitness they're born one year apart
oh [ __ ] even the age yeah what do you do
about that man it's kind of crazy but I
do believe that they open like at least
like I don't know 4 million dollars
don't be like that because that even 4
million dollars doesn't give him back 17
years of his life so the state does have
to pay for that [ __ ] they should does he
have any priors because that's the part
that kind of sucks where he might have
had a prior maybe he cleaned up but
they're not his images in the system if
he was squeaky clean this would never
even have never happened exactly because
he wouldn't have even been on the lineup
of the mug shots for the victim and look
at what he did have on his record was
that in 94 he was sentenced in Kansas on
a string of charges related to theft and
sell of steroids so he did have he's
just trying to help people get buff yeah
come on oh yeah and then so it sucks
because the the bad guy Ricky he's
currently incarcerated already in Kansas
and he was in conscious incarcerated
because he failed to register for as a
sex offender twice you [ __ ]
later to a 2003 sexual battery charge
how do you
failed to register like you got to go to
the sex offender DMV and register your
the automatic wait for you like you have
to go through like oh here goes my
yearly registration per second-- Costco
card yeah like I don't know sex
offenders license yeah and so Ricky is
denying his involvement in this entire
robbery $4.99 but it's like it clearly
points to him because at that time in
that near that location of that Walmart
he was living there with his mom Walter
and he like he already had like a whole
history of drug abuse and I expect I'll
discuss what a [ __ ] garbage can man go
to [ __ ] hell you mom he was almost
done with his sentence to pursue the 19
years sentence he spent 17 years man it
was for what robbery yeah for aggravated
robbery that's so crazy how back in the
day aggravated robbery kids you to what
he hears that should barely get you like
bucket a year now dude yeah especially
now they was like orange is the new
black and so here is the who reunited
with his name you look like a [ __ ]
Rick Fox from the LA Lakers dude it's
crazy yeah then he here he is meeting
his granddaughter for the first time oh
my god
and then like seeing his his daughter
and 17 year old daughter now all this
crazy how was your importance everything
they need to make a movie about on 17
years of your life and it's like from a
20s to 30s I know you dude that's like
the best time to hope you guys enjoyed
that video but if you didn't guess what
you can directly contribute to the
articles that we discussed just cruise
on over to the description box below
click on that link to submit your
article also for the next video it's
Pratt up hey
[Music]